has the industrial action going on in
America right now delayed the
announcement of Stargate again
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV the
movie channel
[Music]
so we've been waiting for quite a long
time to finally get Stargate announced
over the last 12 months I have told you
about several almost and how there were
ideas to announce this oh God back in
January and the people in the marketing
were even trying to get this announced
before then but because of the way
basically MGM was when Amazon took over
and how Amazon wanted to completely
restructure the company and then had to
actually get ahead of MGM movies in
place before they could basically go
ahead with the project they wanted to do
it's meant that this has taken a long
damn time now all those things are in
place and we've heard some very concrete
things from lots of different sources
including people that have worked
directly with the Stargate franchise in
the past that this is going ahead that
Mark Fergus will will be the man in
charge of the new franchise the guys to
give us the expanse and that we're
probably going to be getting a cinematic
movie first followed by a TV series this
is all very exciting because we then
heard that it was probably going to get
announced San Diego Comic-Con even
deadline carried this story so we can be
pretty certain we can almost bet the
house on that it was going to happen
but the writer strike is now going into
its fourth week now that is a problem
because the industrial action is also
now spreading the Actors Guild of
America is also now threatening to
strike the producers will probably
follow and the directors the writer
Strikers already meant that there's been
a pretty much complete shutdown in
Hollywood as actors have not wanted to
cross the picket lines so what does all
this mean for the San Diego Comic-Con
and the Stargate announcement we were
hoping for well I have heard that as it
stands right now Amanda Tapping and
Richard Dean Anderson at the very least
were going to appear at San Diego
Comic-Con so if they are going to be at
San Diego Comic Con we can
two plus two equals four a little bit
there and hope that they were going to
be involved with the announcement I
basically said look if this is going to
happen at San Diego Comic-Con some of
the Stargate actors are going to have to
be there and if we heard those rumors
then it would lead us to believe that
yes it was going to happen and it was
going to happen in mid-june
now within MGM there are a couple of
voices it's basically saying is it
really a good idea to announce this
right now and even if we do announce it
what are we actually announcing well
for a start it does seem that the
marketing PR and the executives behind
this plan are kind of split down the
middle a little bit a lot of them say
look let's just go ahead with it anyway
screw it let's just do it let's get it
done let's have some positive news
around MGM let's show them that actually
we're cracking on and we're going to
bring things like Stargate RoboCop Etc
to their screens as quickly as possible
the other side of that coin though
they're people saying this is really in
bad taste to announce this right now it
actually could do the opposite of
bringing positivity to the company it
could actually make us look kind of
callous that we don't give a crap about
the right to strike that we don't care
about the plight of these people that
we're just a heartless company that says
Ah screw you we're going to crack on
anyway now that is a definite
possibility because at the end of the
day at the moment the writers do tend to
have the public sympathy now the other
issue is Amazon is already seen as a
non-caring corporate giant that doesn't
give a crap about the writers Etc this
so this really would just give the
people that already don't like Amazon
even more ammunition
now there is a big concern a little
video about this last week that actually
the Stargate franchise will attract a
lot of online negativity anyway they
called it the rings of power problem
that actually the Stargate franchise
will get a lot of people screaming that
it's going to be a woke load of rubbish
that
um this that and the other
thing don't need that negativity going
into it I'm arguing actually that's why
we should get Brad right involved with
Stargate in some capacity and we do have
a petition online there's a link in the
description you can go and sign that's
already got over 3 000 signatures to say
that you agree with me and the brand
right should in some way be involved in
Stargate I think it will take the win
that a lot of the sales of the people
the same is going to be a negative load
of rubbish and I actually think Stargate
would be better if Brad Wright was
involved
so MGM and Amazon want to avoid as much
of that negativity as they possibly can
maybe announcing right now is the best
way to do that so what am I actually
hearing from my sources at MGM I have
had a little bit of an update for when I
talked about this in the live video
yesterday now apparently there were
quite a few meetings at this end of last
week with PR and marketing people and
they were basically throwing around a
lot of numbers and they actually did get
an outside marketing company to advise
them on this as well apparently that
advice was Doug's announced anything
right now it will backfire on you and it
will make you look like you don't care
so it does look like at the moment
they're not going to announce that San
Diego Comic-Con does that mean it won't
get announced in the next few weeks
maybe a couple of months well
apparently they might just shift the
idea the apparent idea was to have all
of the actors up on stage to announce
this to make the audience go crazy to
make all those gators go crazy they may
just announce it as a press release
instead they may just release this as a
hey look this is what we're going to do
this is what we're working towards
Hallelujah
to be honest I would love the senior
actors up on the stage I'd love to see
them taking questions I'd love to see
that big announcement but I'm not going
to be in the room so on the other hand
do I really care no I want them to crack
on with the announcement I want to know
for certain that Stargate is coming back
the other issue though was what are we
actually announcing because the writers
are on strike the actors are on strike
what are we actually saying we're doing
now they can say this is in early
development
but no scripts can be done
so what are they actually in early
development of now I have heard that
there is a working first draft or second
draft of a Stargate movie
that actually this is something that
Mark Fergus has been looking at and
working on for eight or nine months now
so in theory they could do some of that
development work now they can't write
anything but Executives and stuff can
work with Mark Ferguson penguin and
Parker and you know maybe do some work
in that area it would really depend on
what Mark Fergus was willing to do he
could perhaps get around the strike
stuff by saying that he's not actually
writing anything now that's only one
possibility and that's completely off
top of my head
but it does show the complexity of the
problem Amazon can say we're going to do
star game but they can't really say any
more than that they can't really do
development they can't really start
thinking about when they're going to
film
now the rumor is again that they were
supposed to start filming by the end of
this year
that's going to be a problem if this
gets delayed much further and it's just
kicking the can even further down the
road but what I can say is according to
my sources that a lot of the work has
already been done on this now one of the
reasons why we haven't had this
announcement earlier is because the lady
Mrs Valentina is new to MGM she's now
the head of MGM pictures and that was
the simple reason why these things
weren't announced because they want the
Cinematic release and you need somebody
in charge MGM to be able to do that
so a lot of work and a lot of planning
was already being done by penguin and
Parker how much is really going to
depend on whether we get this announced
sooner rather than later because if a
lot of the work was done the script is
done a lot of the work with the
executives at MGM Etc on working on that
script is done
then perhaps they could start thinking
about actors they could start thinking
about setting up and getting ready for
special effects Etc they could start
thinking about where they're going to
film it and so on because even if the
actors and the writers can't work the
executive's MGM still can now if the
actors also go on strike soon I I really
don't know where we're going to stand
with that because they could in theory I
imagine still negotiate with Amazon and
still talk about what they would like to
do at Christmas when this finally gets
filmed
but if the actors refuse to even talk to
them because of the strike then
obviously that's going to slow things
down again
but guys get into the comments and tell
me what you think is this just one delay
too many do you actually think the
Stargate franchise is at risk that we've
come this far got so close but just like
in 2019 when we got really close to Brad
Wright's return of Stargate is it going
to be snatched away from us at the end
of the day I think the Stargate
franchise is just too big and too
valuable for them to miss this
opportunity that yes okay it might take
a little bit longer because of this
industrial action than we'd like but the
other day it's still going to happen it
really is when not if
but I'd love to know exactly what you
think guys so get in the comments if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you'll never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to patreon.com forward slash
Sidetrack where most of our new videos
end up first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you get to see them
without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
thank you